you have embraced social media and you
have a great sense of humor about it you
seem to enjoy sending out twit pics and
we have one right here you for example
very irreverent way to announce your
marriage picture are you with a Chuckie
Cheese by any chance never been in a
Chuckie Cheese know we are in a friend's
ball pit
what are you please Patrick for a friend
who has everything you give them a ball
pit yeah okay some kind of crazy slang
here you are eating is this you saying
you claim is eating your first slice of
pizza that can't be true you've had
pizza before this oh yes that there was
a big misunderstanding about this of
course I've had pizza but that was my
first slice I had never gone into a
pizza restaurant before and asked for a
slice I didn't know such a thing existed
and by the way where are you talking
about you didn't know a slice existed
yeah what do you mean you order a pizza
you get it this size or it's this size
and you eat most of it so you would
first of all this is how you and I
differ
I eat all of it and get another one but
you you uh what didn't it come pre slice
how are you eating this pizza don't tell
me you're using a knife and fork all
these years
well I yeah this is this is embarrassing
and it certainly enrages my wife because
I do eat pizza with a knife and fork I
know that that is a social abhorrence in
the United States yes crowd getting very
angry right now it's a good thing
there's chicken wire separating them
from us here's the thing a quick little
story my brother and I we used to listen
to the radio every Saturday morning
children's choice and they would play
one very popular Dean Martin song yeah
which that's Volare oh yeah I know
that's where I'm Laurie that's a moral
support yeah yeah yeah
Volare was another soul ra it was a
gladsome worry for years and years my
brother and I believe that the opening
loops that that song went when
the moon hits your eye like a big piece
of pie Wow
because we didn't know what a pizza was
oh you did my I was 22
before I swore pizza oh my god what a
horrible childhood
you